fue una de las cumbres del clima más
largas de la historia después de 12 días
más uno de prórroga en medio de
negociaciones multitudinarias El acuerdo
de la co-27 en charmershake dejó una
sensación de insatisfacción para la
Unión Europea que previamente había
amenazado con retirarse de las
conversaciones si no se acordaban
mejores compromisos sobre emisiones el
texto se quedó corto ya que no adoptó un
lenguaje fuerte para la mitigación de
emisiones contaminantes la Unión Europea
vino para que se adoptara un lenguaje
fuerte estamos decepcionados de que esto
no se lograra lo que tenemos en frente a
nosotros no es un paso adelante
suficiente para las personas en el
planeta no trae suficientes esfuerzos
adicionales de los principales emisores
a aumentar y acelerar sus recortes de
emisiones Y es que para varios líderes
se trata de un retroceso frente al
acuerdo de Glasgow habla de una
reducción rápida de las emisiones pero
no tiene nuevas ambiciones de reducción
de gases de efecto invernadero la cop27
concluyó con muchas tareas y poco tiempo
ya estamos a mitad de camino el acuerdo
de París y la fecha límite de 2030
necesitamos todas las manos puestas en
la obra para impulsar la justicia y la
ambición sin embargo el texto final sí
dejó una victoria para algunos países en
Vía de desarrollo la creación de un
fondo específico que financiará los
países más empobrecidos por las pérdidas
y daños causados por el cambio climático
Estoy muy emocionado muy muy emocionado
Este es un resultado muy positivo para
1300 millones de africanos
según expertos suponiendo que se cumplan
Los acuerdos en su totalidad El mundo
estaría encaminado a los 2,4 grados
centígrados para finales de siglo pero
al ritmo actual el planeta estaría
llegando a los catastróficos 2,8 grados
centígrados muy por encima del objetivo
de los 1,5 grados la siguiente Cumbre
será en emiratos árabes Unidos gran
productor de combustibles fósiles